[Musique]
Certainement
un choix critique Donc pour nous deux
à la fois pour la jeunesse du pays et pour le pays
Je suis né et j'ai grandi
Je suis à Kahramanmaraş, je m'appelle Emrah.
Juniper est professeur d'éducation physique ici.
J'étudie Plus précisément, la gestion du sport
Je lis un très complexe
la situation parce que dans d'autres pays vous savez comme ça
surtout dans les pays européens
nos pairs font des choses plus jeunes
en pensant, riant et s'amusant
Quel genre de politique avons-nous dans le pays?
Nous pensons donc qu'il existe des stratégies
c'est vraiment une situation difficile
franchement j'en parle pas
Je pense que tu devrais mais tu vois
des conditions comme celle-ci vont dans ce sens et je
je parle ouvert
[Musique]
mon frère Hani expert le 15 juillet 2016
Alors un coup d'état le sergent
directement lorsqu'ils apprennent qu'ils participent.
ils se rendent déjà
ils se rendent sans faire de mal à personne
Il y a différents détails dans cette direction, vous savez.
mais bien sûr c'est juste pour moi de leur dire
Je ne pense vraiment pas
mettra les gens en difficulté
ou déclarez-moi un traître
N'est-ce pas doux parce qu'il y a des détails ?
aussi sur
comment c'est bon pour les gens de voter
Ici aussi, il est clairement évident
Je ne parle déjà pas moins que mes discours
Je pense que tu comprends beaucoup
Pas besoin de dire combien
qui est bon pour l'avenir
Si j'y pense, c'est définitivement dans cette direction dans votre jeu.
Je vais l'utiliser pour mes pairs
je voudrais dire franchement
alors ne vous fiez pas à ce que vous voyez
Juste ce que vous voyez sur les réseaux sociaux
Qu'ils ne comprennent pas comment les gens maintenant
Surtout les plus de 40 ans.
juste ce que vous voyez sur les nouvelles
s'ils saignent, ils sont juste sociaux
ne restez pas quand ils le voient dans les médias
Laissez-les enquêter, c'est définitivement dans la voiture
Déjà la prochaine première élection Mon premier vote
le choix que je peux utiliser et c'est quatre
Je l'attends avec impatience Bien sûr je vais l'utiliser
de Recep Tayyip Erdogan, compatible pour
J'utiliserai ton état et ta nation
Quand je le regarde comme un jeune amoureux
à la situation
le côté pour lequel je ne suis pas prêt à voter
qui ne valorisent pas mon armée et ma nation
avec les gens, avec les soi-disant dirigeants
Je te vois coincé dans les mêmes tables
Je te vois assis et c'est le mien
quelque chose d'inacceptable pour
parce que nous
Si nous vivons en Turquie
nous devons défendre nos valeurs
Nous devons protéger nos jeunes
nous devons leur tenir la main
pas à côté de l'état, mais derrière lui
avec des gens debout
cela ne fonctionnera pas
20 ans, quel âge a Mehmet ?
on parle d'économies
pour que ça se termine pour que ça se termine
Il y aura sûrement ceux qui te marcheront sur les pieds
on parle de politique après tout mais
la nation qui croit tout ce qu'elle entend
air-terre se vantant de rien
nous avons des aînés j'espère que ces 20 ans
pour compléter encore 20 ans
J'espère qu'on montera de niveau
[Musique]
J'ai isot
Je ne suis pas né à Istanbul En fait Istanbul
Je suis venu pour des raisons universitaires
document dans le domaine manifestement politique
production et avec
pénétration dans la vie intellectuelle des gens
être capable de faire quelque chose dans le monde
je veux pouvoir changer
Être un plus pour les lgbt est ouvert en Turquie
appartenant manifestement à lgbt en tant qu'identité
à un moment très difficile si un grand
sauf si vous vivez dans une université de la ville
si vous n'étudiez pas à l'université c'est l'empereur
parce qu'autour de toi constamment
Comme vous pouvez le voir, il y a quelque chose sous pression
D'un côté, il y a le sentiment de raconter.
répression état et autorités gouvernement d'abord
et par les autorités
Les sites continuent de le faire à la fois dans les médias
nous pouvons voir les deux
Nous pouvons le voir en action dans les rues.
vous exposer comme une menace
l'ouvre avec lui
L'humain attire d'être dans l'identité
[Musique]
Je n'arrive toujours pas à me décider
Je suis sûr qu'à l'élection présidentielle
Du parti CHP du parti principal Molped
Il vote pour Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu
Je le serai, mais quant au Parti, qui
si le député est toujours sur le point de partir
Je suis indécis, franchement, pour Türkiye en fait
je prévois un beau spectacle
Malgré les négativités car en Turquie
notre plus gros problème en ce moment
où il n'y a pas de culture de la démocratie
se battre en disant quelque chose
nous travaillons comme une sortie de ceci
Nous sommes déjà bloqués tout le temps, mais
la démocratie après les élections
Je vois l'atmosphère dans cette atmosphère
quelque chose si vous pouvez au moins discuter
dire quelque chose à quelqu'un
Je vois que tu peux défendre notre opinion
[Musique]